Rummel I love Rumble but  Rumble has problems what problems I mean  technical problems well they owe me  millions of dollars to start with  because they've put uh ripped copies of  my movie up like every single day even  though I know the CEO I know the  Acquisitions guy I know every single  person over there and they can't get the  YouTube algorithm where you give YouTube  an imprint of your content and there  there can be no uh bootleg versions and  so it's like you know everyone who  claims the money for you or something or  a lot right exactly and so like well  well once well we're on YouTube like  we're on Google Play so it doesn't do  that but um and isn't that funny he'll  actually the only once we were on  YouTube meaning we were helping YouTube  make money did they do that for us for  the rest of the time we had to do phys  every single link had to be an actual  takedown